each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available so uh it's my pleasure to
welcome uh tuni who is a graduate
student of Todd AR at CMU um he's on the
job market obviously um he's done some
really interesting work over the uh past
few years with in both the architecture
um the programming languages and the
systems Community uh really brings a
very broad diverse background and he's
going to be talking about his uh PhD
work today so welcome great
okay thanks Jim uh thanks for the
introduction um it's uh good morning
everyone thank you so much for coming
for my talk um it's um um I'm just going
to get straight into the talk uh Jim has
done a pretty good
introduction so uh I guess everyone here
is probably very well familiar with the
challenges that uh defects and softwares
uh create uh for computer systems that
we use today in particular when the bugs
actually make their way onto the systems
of end users right um and so uh this has
raised uh created a lot of interest in
uh tools that can actually monitor
program while it's executing in order to
identify bugs and mitigate their harmful
effects and so one could in in our case
we call this uh sort of tools uh
lifeguards and in particular what's
interesting about lifeguards is that
they able to actually operate on
unmodified binaries so you can imagine
deploying a liveu for example to block
security attacks at least until the user
is able to uh you know patch the
software appropriately and so live
guards basically complement a lot of the
efforts that developers make uh to uh
prevent bugs from uh getting out into
the into the wild um so for this reason
there's been a lot of proposals for
lifeguards lifeguards for finding
different kinds of bugs uh ranging from
things like data races to memory faults
or security vulnerabilities in
programs so a little more about how
lifeguards work I'm going to use this T
check which is a security lifeguard to
sort of illustrate how lifeguards work
in general so T check is a lifeguard
that attempts that tries to prevent
input based uh security attacks so in
particular this are the kind of attacks
that would come in perhaps through a
network packet as we have here in this
piece of code uh and will actually that
attempts to take control of your program
and the way T Che does this so let me
just fill out this the rest of this code
of this vable code the way T Che detects
this sort of attacks is basically by uh
Track by tagging input that comes from
untrusted Source like the network as
being tainted or untrusted and then sort
of um tracking how tained data
propagates through the program as the
program executes such that uh when we
get to a point where we about to make a
control flow operation based on value
that we got from the network then T
check is actually steps in and stops the
execution and uh consequently stops the
attack right and so uh what what's
interesting about lifeguards or what's
interesting about t check in this case
is that it actually maintains metadata
about the registers and memory locations
which enables it to track how taint uh
the taint status of data propagates
through this
locations to deploy T check today or any
other lifeguard for that matter the
standard approach is basically to
instrument your your binary your code uh
your binary and there are a number of uh
platforms or Frameworks available uh
that do Dynamic binary instrumentation
such as V grind or pin and so many
others and basically essentially the way
that works is so if we just consider
this piece of EX 6 code here um in
particular this move from a memory
location into a register what would
happen is that the uh the the this
instruction will be instrumented with
the corresponding T check rule for
propagating the T status of the memory
location into that of the register and
that applies for the other kind of the
other instructions there as well we will
propagate uh the T status of uh from the
source to the destination in
general and what's great about doing
this is that we are actually able to
detect bugs early in particular bug
instructions are identified before they
even execute and they can be squashed
but there's a downside to doing this
which is basically that our program
becomes slower now I have sort of shown
T code in terms of cud code but if we
sort of dive in and see exactly what's
going on with each one of these rules it
requires a number of instructions
basically to propagate taint so
essentially we're uh spending a number
of instructions to analyze each
instruction in the program so if I
inline all of the necessary T check code
here our code suddenly becomes very slow
becomes very big and consequently very
slow and so if you then look at the
program at a very high level in terms
and this let's say we're looking at a
program execution where time goes from
top to bottom essentially what we see is
that the program the instrumental
program spends a lot of it becomes a lot
slower and a big chunk of that time is
spent actually running um live gut code
right which which makes everything
slower so this leads to the question
well um and and uh in terms of how this
plays out there I mean here I'm listing
some tools some lifeguard tools that are
out there that have been deployed on on
binary uh using instrumentation and we
see slowdowns average slowdowns ranging
from 10x to 30X so sort of like an order
of magnitude is lost basically by the
fact that we're instrumenting our
programs with this very sophisticated
analysis sophisticated lifeguards and
and it so you know the mix the fact that
we're coupling them together means our
program has to run as slow as the
Lifeguard itself which kind of leads to
the question well what if we could
decouple the LIF Guard from the program
itself and this is what I mean by that
if we had the notion that we could run
the Lifeguard separately from the
program so what happens then well we um
improve and and to and uh of course you
know we sort of the liveu itself needs
some way to know what to check so we I'm
assuming that we can you know stream an
instruction traes of the program to the
liveu for the liveu to Performance
checking and I'm assuming here that we
could do this s efficiently as I'll talk
about later um so one immediate per uh
impact is the fact that performance
improves right we live in a world where
there are many cores there are a lot of
parallel computing resources available
so having the program and the liveu run
on separate Resources with little
interference just makes them run faster
basically right and in fact we saw this
um in the initial research work that I
did in this direction called The Log
based architecture LBA we saw a scenario
where um T check the average slowdown of
T check dropped uh from 30X to 3.4x
Simply by running T check sep on a
separate core from the
program another benefit benefit of the
coupling is uh which is what I spend
most of my time working on is that the
live good actually becomes easier to
optimize the life good code can be
optimize and in particular and I'll talk
a lot more about this later it's much
easier uh to or more effective to
parallelize the Lifeguard or even apply
interesting compiler optimizations on
the liveat code uh basically by
decoupling it and I have some results uh
here where we see that the average slow
down for 10 check so this is on top of
the improvements we had before by simply
separating them we could actually get
additional improvements so the by
parallelizing we could get the average
slowdown of 10 check down to about 2X
and uh and by applying some interesting
pth based optimizations on the live good
code we could actually get a slow down
down to about
2.5x so a final benefit of decoupling
The Lifeguard from the program is that
it makes it it it gives us a lot of
flexibility in terms of ensuring the
Integrity of the Lifeguard in particular
what this means is that we can actually
run the liveu in a separate fault domain
from the program now when you're
monitoring privilege code like device
drivers which you know can you know
destroy your system in all sorts of
interesting ways this is actually very
useful and this is a big part of my uh
thesis which I'll talk about later on in
terms of monitoring device drivers and
the decouple uh and how decoupling helps
with
that so I've sort of talked about all
the benefits of uh decoupling of course
there is some downsides to it and
probably you've s of you've been
thinking about that already which is
basically we lose this guarantee of
being able to detect bugs early in fact
we only detect bugs after some DeLay So
as an example here I have you know this
piece of code here on the left hand side
and there's a bug there and we don't
detect that until much later when the uh
lifeguard is able to analyze the you
know the trace that comes from that
execution and so what this means is that
containing the side effects of bugs is
becomes much more difficult but this is
a challenge that I have tackled in my
research in terms of monitoring
applications and also monitoring in the
kernel space and I'll talk more about
that
later so uh this is sort of the road map
for the rest of this talk um I'll start
out with uh the my early work that I did
in terms of how do we um how do we take
advantage of the fact that uh lifegard
has been decoupled to actually make the
Lifeguard faster and I'll talk about two
uh ideas that I worked on one who is
parallelizing the Lifeguard um and then
doing interesting path-based
optimizations on lifeguard
and after that then we'll just switch
into the kernel space and say what what
do the coupling buyers in terms of you
know monitoring device driver execution
to mitigate bugs and there I will
describe a framework which I built for
my thesis called godril which actually
allows you to uh sort of protect the io
state from bugs in the device
driver I'll conclude by basically giving
some uh a brief uh description of what I
consider to be my future research
directions and then summarize my
contributions and so switching to the
point to the uh to the section where
we'll talk about um how to optimize
lifeguard code after it's been decoupled
I'll start out by first motivating how
do you uh actually decouple lifeguards
in the application space and here I'll
be describing the log based architecture
project that I worked on much earlier um
and how uh that helps to decouple
lifeguards and then I'll go into the
optimization techniques which is
paralyzation and path based optimization
and then I'll come back and talk about
some related work that other other works
that have looked into how do we make
life good code
faster so the basic idea behind log
based architecture or LBA is that since
we live in a world where we have many
cores available Why Don't We Run The
Lifeguard in a separate processor from
the program and if we do this what we
get is um Improvement in performance
like I showed you before and so uh
moreover since uh you know the
transistor density is also increasing
then perhaps we could dedicate some more
uh you know some some more gates into
like uh helping us uh stream uh uh the
instruction Trace so we're using
Hardware to stream the instruction trads
from the application to the program that
way we avoid the software cost of of
instruction traing and so we built uh uh
we um so we built we built this design
and basically we um reserved some amount
of memory uh to sort of cach the the log
uh the trace and um so here um The
Lifeguard in this case then ends up
becoming like basically a collection of
event handlers because what's happening
is we are streaming the application
events with the instruction stream to it
and the liveu is just responding and
invoking the right analysis code to sort
of uh do the the right checking now the
containment guarantees that we make in
this design is basically that even
though it might take us a while to
detect a bug but the the guarantee is
that the bug will actually not propagate
out outside the process context of the
application and we're able to achieve
this in a couple of ways one is the
Lifeguard itself runs as a separate
process so it's sort of uh isolated from
the application and two is that we
actually stall the program when it gets
to uh when it tries to interact with the
kernel so at system called boundary we
stall it there until the live can
actually catch up and we also stall it
of course when our buffer uh for which
we use for the instruction tracing fills
up and so with this design we were able
to achieve uh some sign significant
improvements I have shown the T check
numbers before but for example a tool
like address check which basically
checks yes do you do some flow control
where you throttle the application um
because life guard is too slow so that
shows up basically as the slow down
numbers yeah so we the tring happens
because we have a fix size buffer and so
once that fills up then um it indicates
how much faster the program is than the
Lifeguard and so so that show how does
the signaling happen how does the
signaling happen uh so we do that in the
operating system so we have some
operating system support here
yeah okay um so address check is a tool
that basically checks for access to on
allocated memory and we saw like an
improvement uh reduce a Slowdown
relative to De uh to Binary
instrumentation from 19x to 3.2x uh lock
set looks for data races and we were
able to reduce the Slowdown from uh 30X
slow down to like about 4.3x slowdown
and so we and M Che was probably where
we had the least improvements but we
still had like close to a 3X Improvement
in this case and so this is sort of the
Baseline for the rest and so this is the
Baseline for the rest of the portion of
this talk uh where I'm going to talk
about how then do we you know tackle so
the the slowdowns you're seeing here as
the question alluded to is really the
overhead of the live computation itself
the fact that we're using multiple
instructions to analyze each instruction
in the program and so the question is
how can we make this better
and so uh the first idea that I pushed
was well can't we parallelize the life
God right um and to sort of see why this
will make sense so let's excuse me
imagine we have an application here and
we're just looking at time going from
top to bottom and we're looking at you
know four instructions here in the
instrumented case what ends up happening
is we mix up you know the analysis we
inter leave the analysis with the with
the code and this is really hard to
parallelize because it sort of requires
the original code to be also paralyzed
otherwise you can't even paralyze here
but decoupling helps us because now if
we decouple the uh analysis of the
Lifeguard from the program then the
question is can the analysis itself be
paralyzable that's the problem we have
and we see that this is possible because
um The Lifeguard is running behind the
application it means that the
application is creating streams of
events to be processed and so there's no
reason why we can't just fire off
another lifeguard to process the streams
that are further up in in future which
the lifegard can't get to right now now
and this way we can get
improvements is that automatic or does
that require program support on the
actual lifeguard so as a do I have to
have language support as a comp as
someone who writes a lifeguard for
instance Val
um we let's see so the way this works is
yes you we have some minimal API that
you need to specify that you interested
in particular you need to specify how
many parallel how much parallelism you
want um uh because that sort of goes to
and it only makes sense if you have as
many cores so yeah there is some minimal
API that you need to change yes it's not
even necessarily easy even if you have
the API I mean if you're trying to do
Tain tracking I am going to get to that
in a
second yes as uh the questioner
suggested there are serial dependencies
on what the Lifeguard is doing so hey
particular T check is a perfect example
for this like it showed before in order
to detect the security attack T check
needs to track uh the propagation of
data and this is inherently uh
sequential in fact this uh Tangi falls
into this class of lifeguards that do
this kind of propagation called Dynamic
information flow tracking or diff for
short and so mem Che which detects
unsafe uses of uninitialized memory or
on initialized data also has the same
behavior they they are very very
sequential the computation they do is
very sequential so how do you handle
this and so I uh I came up with this
algorithm for parallelizing diffs uh
which essentially works as follows so
here let's say we have this instru uh
stream of application events that we
want to process um over um what we first
do is we break this up into segments and
then run that in parallel uh we in
parallel we run an algorithm called
symbolic inheritance tracking now the
basic idea here is that rather than
trying to track the propagation
concretely we can symbolically track how
in uh taint is inherited and I'll show
that some some more details about that
later but it turns out that you can do
this in parallel right
now when you're done with that then we
can then process each of the segments uh
sequentially uh resolving because
essentially since we don't because of
the dependencies we will still have some
unresolved issues uh dependencies in
there and we call this uh the solving of
this call we call it inheritance
resolution which is sort of the F Next
Step where we then sequentially go
through each segment and then resolve
all of this inheritance now what's
interesting about this is that we can
actually perform this in parallel in
terms of the location right so
individual locations we can resolve
their inheritance in parallel but then
we for each segment we have to sort of
do that um
sequentially and so with this design we
came up with an algorithm uh that
basically has this this nice uh property
although that it uh has astoic linear
speed up although in practice the
constant factors really prevent us our
implementation from actually having this
Behavior now so what do I mean by
inheritance symbolic inheritance
tracking so the the idea here is that so
here we're in parallel we're in the
first phase where we trying to uh you
know uh uh propagate The Inheritance
here and so let's start with the very
first instruction where we're copying
from memory location MX into R1 well
what is the Tain status of of MX what we
don't know well that's fine all we just
record there is the fact that well the
the Tren the our uh the 10th status of
R1 now is whatever the 10th status of MX
was in the previous segment okay and
then we just sort and so that's the
inheritance so we can then sort of
propagate this along as uh the program
executes and so we end up in this
scenario where either we're able to
resolve the T status for sure um or we
able to like create an inheritance
saying for the it comes from the
previous
segment and so what we've essentially
done is we've been able to collapse the
propagation chain which would have been
a difficulty for us so can you can you
go back to the previous slide sure so
one thing that sort of occurs to me with
this is it looks a lot like carry
propagation and
the and there there are schemes that
involve lots of Hardware to do carry
propagation very fast okay is there an
equivalent for this um I haven't really
thought about that um but I mean
the is it an equivalent for this um I'm
not sure I think there are some slight
differences there because um not in I
mean the idea is that we may not really
know what the true answer is until we
get to the next phase and so you sort of
have to have this sort of not don't care
but um this generic answer like we don't
know what it is so I don't know if the
carry propagation Hardware actually does
that it does when you add two BS
together you don't know whether it's
zero one to carry then and then in that
case then I guess I think it's quite
similar I think it's quite similar
actually yeah I wasn't aware of that yes
so so you'll have to excuse me I'm a
little bit naive on how you do team
tracking but my assumption is that you
do a load and then if you do operations
on that load you to carry taint you just
or yes an or across all of the the
values that you've
loaded um no I'm sorry that set as being
tainted yes then I just or the results
of of when I apply operations on that
load something that's derived from that
load right right so isn't or an
associative
operation it is an associative operation
so then isn't this even though you have
the pendence a the pendence chain isn't
that a parallel operation by definition
so if you if I want to add up a bunch of
numbers I can because addition is
associative I can do this right but but
if you don't know um well okay see
so that's assuming you know one of the
values right like you know it was
tainted but if you don't know you can
make the wrong conclusion so it is an
Associated value but it still depends on
the input values right so if it's all
untainted the or wouldn't change it but
if it's if at least one of the input
values is Tainted then the final answer
is Tainted at least that's the rule so
maybe I should have clarified that so if
at least one of the values is Tainted
then the whole competition is Tainted
right that's the challenge I think what
you said is right for each
location right but problem seems to be
that you have the instructions not the
locations but if you have the when you
only need to do an or when you when what
that value surface is that's like guess
the point so you there is some par ISM
in the fact that you can stall until you
actually get you know into what you have
I see okay and then apply to order it's
very fine gr yeah yeah yeah right yeah
um yeah so you sort of have to carry all
the values along is that what you're
suggesting and that um so yeah we
actually had some sort of similar
problem the problem is that the amount
of computation that you need the amount
of stor that you need to carry that
along is huge and it actually just kills
your performance completely um so right
um all right so here we are um so here
we've been able to collapse the
propagation chain and we at the point
where we know that the only Tain values
that we cannot resolve here are the ones
that are dependent on the previous
segment okay and so then we then move
into the inheritance resolution uh stage
and because like I said we do that
sequentially so in other words we first
resolve all the segments in J minus one
and we have this nice property that then
they can be done parallel because they
uh well I'll show that in a second but
now we're ready to resolve the uh tains
for our uh the values in segment J and
we can also do that we can do that in
parallel because they all depend on one
um on they have one sort of predecessor
um your question that you ask sort of
alludes to the issue of there might be
binary uh dependencies here as well um
we here we assume that um for this for a
particular lifeguard it you uh it's
possible to have like a simplifying
operation so for T Che for example
when you combine uh to um uh it's uh let
me see how I can rephrase this for MCH
for example um if you have uh two on one
at least one un initialized value it
doesn't matter what the other value is
and so for T check as well if you have
one tint value it doesn't matter whether
the other value is untinted so you can
actually always uh collapse it easily
and so that's uh we we get this nice
property there we don't need to worry
about uh binary
operations um and so once we resolved
this then we can go ahead and then
resolve uh sort of resolve the
inheritance for the next
segment and okay and so in terms of the
implementation I basically built um uh
parallel T check in this s in in this
way where I have a bunch of parallel
workers but I have a uh my inheritance
resolution is done sequentially so I
have a single uh tread doing The
Inheritance uh resolution and so we sort
of call them the parallel workers and
then we have a master say essentially um
and a way to sort of compare this to uh
uh to to sequential Tain check is that
you assume that you have the the master
is equivalent to one sequential uh uh
tin check and then you you give it a
bunch of parallel workers to sort of
help it improve
performance and so what does this look
like in terms of performance these are
some spec benchmarks and here I am
showing speed up over LBA so over a
sequential T check running on LBA and we
we we saw some pretty decent
improvements and this is with it work so
the speed up is not quite linear but um
but we did see some interesting
improvements um and we saw in some cases
up to 3.4x on average we saw about a 1.7
improvements um over the sequential
approach using eight workers and this
sort of shows that there is
opportunities to improve performance by
parallelizing um we might even get some
more if I had parallelized the master
for example um so but but we did yes so
what's the Slowdown of uh te check with
LBA with LBA uh with LBA is about 1.9x
so showed that a bit
earlier okay so yes picture you show
that one processor is both a worker and
a master um
question the the left most uh oh so you
mean this this left most one oh sorry
actually sorry that's not what's going
on here so this are the workers like the
symbols indicates the workers and the
only re the only only thing I'm doing
here is the fact that uh so there are
four segments and then the work uh the
master which is the symbol works on each
of the four segments so I maybe this
figure is confusing it's not really like
the the same processor I mean it could
be but it doesn't have to be do you know
is the master of the bottleneck here no
it's not actually um it actually turns
out not to be the the the bottl neck
here really is that um th this uh
inheritance tracking doesn't shrink the
like the segments that come out of it is
still quite big um and so um we I mean I
mean we could either try to like break
down segments even more but it turns out
not to help so much right how big is big
big is like half of what it gave so it
only shrinks it by
half so like the I give it a segment and
it only shrinks it by half and then the
other thing the the number of upwardly
exposed values is half what's in yes yes
only OB eliminates half of the yeah so
how big is the the segment though in
terms of instructions um I think for
this uh it was played around with a I
think this is probably like uh 16k this
results were for 16k yeah 16,000
instructions um the probably the other
interesting thing which I sort of left
out is that the inheritance resolution
is about twice as slow as uh just
propagation so you you you so that's
this this guy guys are you know half the
speed of uh of of the of the sequential
uh T check so that's the cost you get
for symbolically tracking inheritance
rather than actually tracking um
propagation any more questions
okay all right um and so what if you
don't have many cores to um you know to
to to commit to making your life good
faster what else can you do well one
approach is well why don't you do uh Pat
based optimizations you might ask why p
Bas optimizations for lifeguards well
because the compiler Community is shown
for so many years that you know most
programs the execution time is dominated
by a few hot pths now so if we consider
what happens when we instrument those
hot pths uh we see a number of results
and so here I have instrumentation of
the hot pads the colored bars are the
analysis code I've used different colors
in this case so maybe hopefully delates
the the different uh the different uh
instrumentations while the the black
lines are basically the original code
and so we have something like this like
one of this basic blocks will open up to
something like this where we still have
um a lot of analysis code in there well
so if we consider one such hot path
that's been instrumented we can conclude
a number of things one is that the lifu
code uh is actually spend most of its
time analyzing the hot paths right so
the overhead of the lifu itself mostly
comes from the hot paths it ALS it also
means that if we could somehow optimize
how the live
you know analyzes this hot paths which
run frequently then you know we could
improve performance
overall but the challenge to doing this
in with instrumentation is that this
requires you to analyze across two
different kinds of code right there's a
program code and the analysis code and
there's some context switching code in
between them this is just really really
complicated right to find um uh uh
redundancies here and this is where
decoupling help us helps us right so by
decoupling the analysis from uh the life
good from the program we can just focus
on the life good code itself and see if
we can um uh to see if we can improve it
by analyzing along paths and so here I
have basically the life get code that is
the correct uh analysis code for this
particular program path and we call that
sort of unoptimized because we sort of
just pull them out and sort of execute
them in order um and so it's
unoptimized now even with a standard
compiler you could imagine that if you
inlined all of this code together a CER
compiler could probably find
Opportunities to you know concept
propagate or maybe save some saving
restores here um so we could get some
improvements there but the real big win
comes from the fact that you know live
guards have a particular way they
compute right so T check propagates uh
and so if we could exploit uh the domain
knowledge of this lifeguards we could
actually get even bigger optimizations
and one example which I'll talk about
today is uh how live access their
metadata so the metadata is basic
basically what you know the taints
values how they access it and also you
could also eliminate things like the
Redundant checks you could find
redundant checks because you know that's
what the the liveu is doing and as an
example so here is um the pat andler for
a particular mcf for particular
Benchmark from spec mcf we start out
with like a path Handler that's the T
analysis path Handler that had 86 x86
instructions right now when we sort of
compose the pat analy together and and
give it to um standard compiler to do
inlining and Conant propagation we're
able to like eliminate 5% of the
instructions but when we apply 10 Che
specific optimizations we're actually
able to Blow Away about 45% of the
instructions it's like a big
win so um I talked about how metadata
access is like the big is like a big um
uh you know uh source of overhead in in
in in in lifeguard so let's consider
taint check for example and I'd shown
this before where you know to propagate
the taint of a memory location into that
of a register requires like seven X6
instructions but what's interesting is
that six of the instructions are all to
derive the metadata and the reason for
this is because to um most live guards
use two level tables to Shadow the whole
memory right this is like the probably
the most flexible way of doing this
right so you have six instructions uh
that you have to execute each time to
just to you know uh obtain the metadata
so the question is what can we do to
improve this um just looking at the anal
uh the life good code itself and I mean
I've represented the memory locations
with a BC and D it's very hard to say
whether there's any similarities in this
because remember all of this is just
coming is streaming this values are just
streaming in from the log to the
analysis and it's hard for us to tell is
there any real value here I mean are
they similar is there optimization
opportunities here but instead what if
we looked at the application path itself
and if we do that we see something very
interesting so I've here I've circled
all the correspondent uh memory accesses
in the path in the uh in the mcf program
and what we can see here well is like
the first three are exactly the same
address because you know the the the the
the register doesn't change so it's
exactly the same address so you know A
and C ABC are actually a right and then
what's also interesting that even in
even though the last one is not the same
address it's actually close enough it's
like 64 bytes away from a which
basically means there's a high
probability that it falls into the same
second level table so we can actually
you know the the uh you know the the the
page table we could leverage some of the
work that we've done for accessing a we
could use it to also uh access B um the
uh the other uh location d uh much
faster now what was interesting at least
cool to me when I when I when I did this
was like wow I wanted to optimize my
lifeguard but I couldn't find anything
in my lifeguard code that to help me I
had to go and look into another program
which is basically the application that
I'm monitoring and there I was able to
find uh you know useful information that
was able to enable me to implement this
optimization and so it's like an
interesting uh for me it was really cool
being able to like optimize a program by
looking at another
program um and so this where this is
basically where the results that we had
uh that I got for this and so here I'm
showing average speed up over uh LBA on
the y axis uh in percentages and I'm
showing two results one is uh if you
give a path and that you've composed to
standard compiler and could perform in
lineing and St you know constant
propagation what kind of improvements
would you get and then when you
implement a live lifeguard specific
optimizations like the kind of described
and here we see that well standard
compiler does pretty well in some cases
like GCC you could uh get a 20 uh% 21%
improvement over standard LBA but in
some cases it's bad and it's like lock
said the problem here is the fact that
when we inline all this handlers uh we
basically increase the code size and
that hurts right uh but the cool thing
is that with lifeu specific optimization
we always do better and sometimes even
quite significantly like we have a 61%
Improvement here for address
check and and so by leveraging the
domain leveraging domain knowledge of
what the live gut is actually doing you
can actually improve the live gut code
significantly than simply using standard
compiler tricks I something suppose I
ran a profile ER for that tried to
figure out hot basic blocks and hot
functions and then appli that uh
basically inlining and reorganization of
Bas blocks based on that profile
information do you think GCC would then
have been able to pick up a lot of the
opp opposition opportunities at
lifeguards that's exactly what I
did that's exactly yeah so I it's I
figured out the hot paths and I
presented it both to GCC and then to my
my new compiler and this is sort of the
results yeah
yeah okay all
right so so we get improvements this
way all right and so in terms of our
related work into how do we make
lifeguard code faster uh there's been we
could sort of uh categorize them based
on whether they were targeted for couple
lifeguards or decouple lifeguards um so
for the couple lifeguards there were uh
so chin um basically accelerate Tain
check by based on the observation that
most locations have a stable taint value
so they're either always tainted or
always untainted they never really
fluctuate and so was able to use that to
uh do less tint propagation um Dalton uh
basically
um propos doing T check in propagation
in Hardware um and that helps and then
more recently Bosman they've come up
with some interesting techniques of
using um on on machines that have like
itanium that have um machines that have
many registers basically partitioning um
your registers for T checking and for
your actual program and they got some
improvements there and then they had
some interesting uh but custom metadata
organiz iation that probably only works
for T check um um and in the in the
coupled space uh well a bunch of this
work are well two of this work uh the
iscar work we had some Hardway
accelerators um and then this is uh
adway acceleration is with the iscar and
the vacos work um the Nill work actually
was kind of interesting so they uh
parallelized the T check as well um and
basically they found some uh some good
speed ups but one of the results that
they had from there which I didn't about
today is the fact that you need at least
four parallel workers before you can
actually match the speed of the of of
the sequential simply because of the
costum factors and and colise is
basically an ex a hardware extension and
the commit phase where uh the the tinch
uh uh the analysis is performed at
commit time using special
Hardware so um at this point uh we're
going to sort of switch gears and sort
of dive in into the next part of the
work of my talk which is where I'll talk
about using lifeguards in the kernel
space and basically God the God real
work so the outline for this is first
I'm going to motivate why did we
consider device drivers uh as you know
Target application for lifeguards in the
kernel space and um and then I'll give
an overview of uh guardrail and what
sort of the design goals that we had in
mind I'll uh sort of look at some
related work in that space then I'll
talk about how do we do containment
right so we we're going to be detecting
bugs after the fact so how do we do
contain
um and then I'll present some I wrote uh
three new uh driver lifeguards um I'm
going to present their bug detection
Effectiveness and and their end to end
performance so why why why drivers I
guess probably the wrong Community to be
asking this
question well it terms we all I mean
they're they're important part of our
software stack today right they they
allow us to use our Hardware devices
that we love um but unfortunately
they're a major source of of bugs and um
you know uh so one particular operating
system reported that 85% of their
crashes were due to drivers um you know
uh and then the other thing that's
actually interesting about them in terms
of runtime monitoring is the fact that
drivers are actually very sensitive to
perturbations which is something that
you don't see in the application space
so this is because a lot of their
computation is timing sensitive so
responding to interrupt is timing
sensitive if you stall it significantly
enough you actually break the driver and
so for this reason this has been the key
limitation to applying sophisticated
analysis to drivers right because you
slow them down enough you just introduce
a new set of reliability issues right
asides the one you're looking
for so um so what does guardrail do um
so guardrail is our uh is a system that
I built for um using decoupled analysis
uh to actually uh mitigate uh driver
bugs in particular I'm looking to
protect the iio states uh the prent iio
state from driver bugs and the way Gil
works is basically it streams the
destruction trait to the Lifeguard
and then it interposes on the inter on
the interface between the driver and the
device such that um iio operations are
not allowed to pass through this until
they've been verified by The Lifeguard
and so there the Lifeguard can run any
habitually sophisticated analysis that
you can think
of and so with this we had like uh a
number of design goals uh which uh uh
which God will meets so the first is we
wanted containment right so we wanted to
protect uh the external worldall
starting from the device uh from Bugs
and driver we have the unfortunate
effect that the operating system kernel
is still sort of suscep vulnerable to
driver bugs and we're is that because
the The Lifeguard runs after the
instruction has already covered your
kernel yes because we don't have an
interposition layer there yeah are you
going to tell us how you implement the
into position there on the other side
cuz I'm not sure how you do that one
either Oh you mean on the Kernel side no
on the on the between the driver and the
okay
yeah um um and also the fact that we run
the live guard in separate protection
domain which I talked about earlier
means that even if the driver hoses the
system our liveu is still able to at
least tell us what went
wrong but in reality here we we um yeah
if the driver hoses the kernel the
library can still tell us exactly what
went wrong we
also um yes in an interesting way I'll
get to that too in a
second right right um so the other um uh
sort of design goal we had was
generality like so drivers suffer from a
variety of bugs buffer overflows data
races all sorts that you can think of
security vulnerabilities and so we
wanted a system that allowed us to
allowed lifeguard writers to write
orbituary analysis and we sort of hit
that by making the uh lifeguard sort of
be a separate component that you can
just Implement your new analysis in it
and um and so in particular and and also
our interposition layer is actually
transparent it doesn't require changes
to either the driver or the device and
so it allows for generality allows us to
support orbitary combinations of drivers
and devices and in particular in my in
this work I looked at about 11 uh Linux
drivers from four different classes so
audio storage uh Network um and the
disk um so yeah and also I implemented
three uh new lifeguards um for finding
uh concurrency oper instant protocol
errors such as dma and then memory
safety um
yes specify prevention of Corruption of
or state itself sorry I can so so do you
prevent Corruption of other or state or
just the coruption of the device of the
device yeah so here we're just
safeguarding iio the io state from um
from the from the driver bugs yeah so
yeah the colonel is is within with is
vulnerable to bugs and the driver and
this in guard rail do do you actually
run the lifeu completely offline you saw
this is online this is all online
how much buffering do you have to do for
this instruction trade because that can
explode very fast right um it doesn't
matter it it it really doesn't explode
so far because when you think about um
the amount uh the instance of time when
drivers execute it's only uh for brief
periods within your overall execution
time and so the driver is not on like
applications which are like could be CPU
intensive and run all the time drivers
only run intermittently and they might
run for re burst but then you know they
they go off and do some IO and and they
don't run for a while right yeah okay
questions um so detection Fidelity is
essentially that some bugs just require
instruction level analysis and so we
want to support that and we do that by
basically U providing the Lifeguard with
an instruction trace and finally uh
trustworthiness um and the idea here is
that well ultimately we have to make
some changes to the trusted Computing
base and we wanted that to be minimal
and and in particular the iio inter
position is the only layer that we need
that really needs to be into trusted
Computing base and by ensuring that the
only thing that it does is basically
intercepts um uh you know the operation
uh interaction between the driver and
the device it doesn't really do any sort
of computation to detect errors that's
actually uh decoupled off to the
Lifeguard so that way we can uh you know
it's it's it's at least uh conceptu it's
very
simple and so that helps for the the the
trustworthiness of a uh
TCB now in terms of existing work in
this direction um in terms of driver
reliability has been a lot of work um I
think we can C categorize ex existing
Dynamic approaches in along two
different axis so the first axis which
are the columns here is exactly when
does the dynamic approach perform its
correctness check-in right so you have
the coupled approach uh which is you
perform the check-in before every driver
instruction or the decoupled which is
sort of like uh you know my work
guardrail style where you do uh the
check-in at some time
later and on the uh other dimension is
how much of uh the driver execution is
checked by the dynamic analysis so you
could either check all of the driver
instructions or there are a lot of
techniques that check only the uh API
interaction between the driver and
either the kernel or the device now
these design points matter because they
impact things like performance right so
a good way to one way to improve
performance is basically to check just
the API calls right you you you ignore
like the bulk of the driver execution
right another way to improve to get good
performance is to decouple it so run it
run the checks you know sort of
asynchronously but of course this all
comes at a price right so if you check
only the API the driver API then you
have poor Fidelity in the sense that you
miss a lot of bugs that occur within the
driver itself and of course if you
decouple then you have this containment
challenge which I'll get to uh a little
later um and of course the other
properties sort of fall in in place and
so in terms of our existing uh uh
approaches uh map in the sort of we have
this sort of picture and so perhaps the
most immediate one to observe is that
there's only uh one prior work that does
like decouple checking and that's after
sight um and after side provides like no
uh containment at all so it's only good
for like I mean it's it doesn't protect
protect anything it's just put it that
way because it detects the errors after
the fact it has no
containment and so in terms of the
coupled approaches which is majority of
approaches we see that there's a lot uh
of work in uh checking only the API to
improve performance right so it's where
people sort of uh um optimize for so
they want good performance and so they
only check API and so of course the the
problem with that is that you know you
miss some actual bugs so guard sort of
sits here in the decoupled then checking
all the driver instruction space right
and you know the downside there is a
containment and and and and I'll
describe how how I how I address that
how I solve
that can you say what you mean when you
when you put like software fault
isolation um in the the upper half of
this I mean I I usually think of that as
checking all instructions that that run
right so it's software solution is
basically almost like sandboxing so it's
the idea is you're you're fine with the
with the module that you're checking
corrupting its own internal data
structure but you're just saying it will
not get out but the problem there is so
the problem there is that well why you
could prevent things like you know uh
rights that would directly corrupt you
know the external world
but there's a question of whether your
module itself is behaving correctly at a
fundamental level I mean if it's you
know constantly overflowing its own
buffers or corrupting its data is it
even doing the right thing it might not
be able to corrupt uh the the kernel but
is it even providing the functionality
that you wants so so you're worried that
it's going to corrupt the device because
inside the driver the wrong things are
happening yeah inside exactly and it's a
good point right so even like a lot of
the uh false isolation is really been
about you know the interface between the
driver and the kernel really the
interface between the driver and the and
the device is something that uh you know
that doesn't actually fall into that as
well but even just is my driver behaving
correctly right even if it's not
crashing is it displaying the right
images right it it may display the wrong
images without actually crashing a
kernel um but then that's not what you
want right the follow question is how
many of those crates that you mentioned
are actually because
of uh
because of uh things I mean drivers
doing bad things to the devic they doing
bad things to the rest of the US well um
how many of which crashes
uh some uh well I mean I didn't mention
any particular crashes but but I can
answer your question and uh the answer
there is that yes uh the the challenge
is that um while let put this way so
crashes that are come from the driver
corrupt and the kernel are well studied
and there a lot of numbers there
unfortunately crashes that come from the
driver corrupting the device uh there
not that many numbers on them but there
have been some really interesting cases
so for example a few years ago there was
this E1000 network card that was
basically being hosed by a
driver right and you know your network
car literally just dies and the other
challenge there is is if your driver
actually hoses your your your disc for
example it could cause some other kind
of failures that's just impossible to tr
R so it's really hard to actually
quantify how bad this is so I mean
imagine that the driver actually
corrupted your the your virtual um well
so you have virtual memory right so
you're storing stuff on dis and you
think your virtual memory is working
well what if the driver just scribbled
over all of your virtual memory metadata
right your operating system starts
failing in all sort of orbitary ways and
it's lit very hard to uh sort of
quantify this I think this is part of
the challenge why you know there hasn't
been a really good study in terms of
this kind of failures because they tend
to be very catastrophic
anyway yeah
questions okay um so right um but then
so the other dimension to look at uh
Dynamic approaches is what system
components are they protecting and uh
like I said well most of the work has
really been in terms of protecting the
operating system kernel it's only
recently uh that people started looking
at protecting the iio uh device States
and so godil sort of falls into that
space right so we thought that was like
an interesting area to go after the
other space is really well congested um
there's been a lot of good work and
interesting results from that direction
so I decided to just pursue this new
space that is fairly new can you talk a
little bit about Nexus rvm protects both
right both it protects both yes yes so
um so Nexus rvm um protects the uh
kernel by basically running the drivers
in user space okay so that has memory
protection and then it protects the
device by uh basically it requires you
to have it requires the hardware to
basic Bally write a reference validator
uh which indicates how the driver should
interact with the device and so by
trapping all this so now that the the
driver is in user space you can
essentially trap all of the um all of
its well you basically change its API
such that all of its interaction with
the device actually turns into system
calls and so you can interpose on that
and then check that against the model
right which which sits and the reference
monitor sits in the kernel and then
verifies basically that the driver is
you know interacting with the device in
the right way the reference monitor has
to be written manually yeah it has to be
written manually it's very hard it's
it's specific to that particular device
and you know and it's not clear that um
you know it could be written in an open
source fashion because for devices that
are proprietary it's it reveals way
probably way too much about the the the
the the smarts that go into the device
itself right so sorry performance yeah
yeah so so yeah but but it was really
the first work to really look into into
Dynamic lay and they also made this
interesting observation in that work
where they said like you know what we
banged on our device hard enough without
rvm and then our device stopped
functioning right so they they send like
all sorts of random data like inputs to
the device and you know they actually
kill the network card as well it's part
of the research kind of cool um so but
guardrail sort of falls into this space
um all right so containment um which I
guess seems like has a bunch of
interests here um so how do we contain
bugs if we detect them after the fact U
how do we prevent it from corrupting uh
the
device so
um so let me just rephrase the the bug
containment challenge here is we have a
driver code it's running it's had a bug
it's gone past the bug so time is going
from top to bottom the analysis is still
somewhere back still checking some of
the it its history and the driver is
going to do a dis right at some point
right and it's like question is okay is
that bug going to INF you know you know
going to cause terrible things when this
discr happens um what can we do to um to
PR prevent this from happening and so in
other words we have this challenge that
we need to preserve our integrity even
though we're detecting bugs after the
fact and so I looked at it and said that
well you know this is because the driver
talks directly to the device so uh why
don't we just uh put something in
between them uh and virtualization
seemed like a really good uh approach to
go so I I I buil something
around a virtual uh virtual machine
monitor where I added an interposition
layer here and so in this so in with
guardrail so this is how iio operations
get executed so first we inter uh the
driver issues and an operation and we
intercept it okay in the interposition
layer and then we send a request to the
Lifeguard which is you know analyzing
and say like oh is it okay to you know
uh let this this access go true if you
like caught up if you I mean eventually
let's say in the good case it says yeah
it's okay you can go ahead and do it and
then so we then the interposition layer
then replays the access um uh um and um
I don't know should I should take your
question okay go ahead it repls the
access now what's cool about this is
that uh this is transparent to the
driver and the device right so the the
the the driver doesn't know that this
you know this interception occurs and
the device doesn't know that the access
is coming from the virtualization layer
not the device right from the not from
the driver right um and in particular we
we do the interception using traps um
and we uh complete operation use an
emulation which um which provides some
performance challenge
question how does work with d with what
dma um so so there are two parts of dma
right there's the control part and then
there's the actual streaming data part
so what we're trapping here is ensuring
that the control part is correct so but
the control part could just be a data
structure like a network transmit Cube
that's sitting in in memory and the
driver is just doing memory rights to
inue packet transmissions by by ining
stuff in a memory data structure and
asynchronously with that the device is
walking this thing in memory and pulling
packets out of it so the control channel
to the extent that he exists the control
channel is just I wrote some stuff to
memory no it's a little more than that
cuz the driver has to tell the device
where the where it wrote stuff into the
driver is not just going to the device
is not going to just go to some orbitary
location and start reading from there no
uh so the driver might tell the device
here's my transmit cube right and the
device starts transmitting right and as
long as the as long as there are still
pack that's in that queue the device
will keep transmitting the network
device will keep transm and the driver
can happily in more stuff there and it
doesn't have to tell the device I've got
another packet I've got another packet
I've got another packet
right um right right so I so this
asynchron um so the the right right
so So eventually right so even with this
asynchrony right at some point right the
driver has to be done and has to tell
the device that it's okay to get the
data at some point
right or either the driver either the
device has to generate an interrupt to
indicate that I have completed I mean
it's a transaction at the end of the day
right so well maybe we should talk
about my argument is that there's a
control Channel but it's asynchronous in
the sense that the driver can get stuff
done without having to invoke that for
every operation and I I I could I I I'm
sure that in this system I could slip
things out to the device without oh no
no no okay so now I okay okay I think
now I get question right so the
the the the driver could write corrupted
data and slip it out but it would not um
modify the state of the device
itself right because the Control Data
that you sending the sorry the data the
IO Data that you your packet cues are
not actually going to affects the state
of the device itself you can only do
that by programming this device
registers and sending them into some
arbitary values let's talk about
okay um so but but by doing this um I
mean there's a performance uh
implication for trapping and emulation
but uh the by doing this the the the
approach the design uh trade-off that I
made was that I would rather like stall
IO uh the device register reads and
writes which are the io operations which
are typically slow anyway and you know
uh they're relatively infrequent um
rather than stall rather than impact the
actual CPU instructions of the driver uh
which are much
faster and but of course there's some
performance overhead implied here and we
can see that here um so here I'm showing
um performance relative to Linux so
where Linux will be one um and so lower
is worse um and here I am um you know uh
evaluating the performance of using Zen
so I built this uh in Zen I added this
interposition layer into zen and so I'm
comparing against Zen and this the
interposition numbers and I did this for
um basically four classes of devices so
audio video disk and network and the
idea is to say what what is the
performance impact of doing this sort of
interposition on every device register
read and write or every operation and um
what we see uh is that in most cases uh
there the overheads is not so much it's
like about 10% and this is because this
operations is a slow anyway to begin
with and then they're relatively I mean
they're infrequent right but there are
cases too where it gets worse right so
one of the um cases where I have very
poor number I'll is on uh compilation
right so where we're losing about 30% of
U performance relative to lens and it
turns out that well the virtualization
Zen is not doing much better so you know
seems like most of that overhead is
coming from virtualization
right uh but um with mcash d where I
have the system fully saturated um you
know um I'm losing close to 40% uh about
40% of the performance um and so here
it's like it shows both both sides of it
so like 20% of that seems to be coming
from virtualization and the other is
coming from the fact that um so I'll
show a little bit later M casd actually
for this particular workload actually
makes the driver do a lot more IO
operations um it um I mean the the the
amount of data the the gets the get size
is about 64 bytes so it's like it's
doing more I operations per B
um and so in in those cases we can see
the slow
downs um so so but in nutshell is sort
of how um the interposition
works so right so now what does this
allow me to do right um even I have that
now I can write some new interesting
tools that have not existed before um
and in particular I wrote these three
tools Dr check DET uh finds data races
uh in in Pro uh in drivers dma checks
finds dma protocol bug bugs um while uh
DM Che finds uh memory bugs on
uninitialized use of uh uh unsafe use of
un initialized data sort of like M
checking the user level um in the
interest of time I'm going to focus only
on the first two so one thing that Ma us
was that the reference monitors they had
the write thing for each device that had
to know about the device the things
you're talking about is the I inter
position and these Checkers are those
per device or those General so the I
position itself is general and the
reason for that is because
uh it only intercepts the memory um it
intercepts the operation in uh sort of
like a device agnostic way so it's
essentially a trap right so the device
the driver will map the device's memory
into its address space and try to touch
it and I mean the details is like then I
just revoke that so that every access to
it becomes a trap and so this works
regardless of the driver or the device
so you just need to know where the the
control Rister are mapped in the yes
exactly right exactly and I mean there
like standard apis for how to do this um
in the kernel and so so yeah at least
within a particular operating system
kernel it's it's it's General in that
sense but to go back to your motivation
of drivers that have bugs that cause
Hardware to be corrupted yes at the
network card thing
yes to catch that you would need to
write a checker that understood the
devices interface so I will put that in
a class so there like I said there are a
wide variety of bugs that drivers could
have so it's receivable that if I gave
you an instruction stream you could
actually write a checker uh instruction
traes of the driver you could actually
write a checker and uh again to check
for what the driver is doing and how
it's programming the device registers
and find such bugs um I didn't look into
that in particular um for my thesis
because one of the challenges of doing
that is you sort of need to know how the
device behaves right and and that seemed
like really hard so this is sort of like
the easiest things I could do using like
open source information
like
right but I believe very much that you
could actually write similar
checks all right um so I'm going to
start with did uh Dr check which finds
data races and so it's a quick primer on
U background on data races so data Ras
essentially is uh two accesses to share
data typically from two different Treads
um um where at least one of the accesses
is a right but and they're not
serialized and so like example we have
here will be database right and like a
lot of the work data Ras detection has
been done in the user space um and so
some of the techniques they've used are
things like trying to infer whether
there's a consistent locking discipline
for protecting shared data so this would
be the lock set approach where we can
see here that this axis here with this
locks here that this axis here is uh is
safe because the X's are consistently
protected with lock LX right and then
the other approach is they use happens
before which is based on the fact that
well you know setting operations are uh
serialized in time so like a lock and an
unlock on the same lock are sort of
serialized and so um you know one
happens after the other and so the
techniques that do this and and so um
here and then in addition they maintain
a vector clock to sort of keep track of
what time was and so here we'll see that
uh we can conclude that you know this
access to uh X here is is uh safe so
this is the vector clock of the variable
and it indicates that tread one wrot uh
access this variable in its Epoch time
of Two And this is the uh Vector clock
for tread 2 and relative to uh it's it's
it's a Epoch time of three for tread 1
and so this so the access is serializing
time and then there are hybrid
approaches that combines because this
this board approaches have uh um um uh
different uh complimenting strengths and
weaknesses and and so um this sort of I
think sort of covers uh there detection
user level so you might ask well why not
just use this tools in the kernel right
what's what's what's interesting U well
it turns out that kernel mode
concurrency in kernel mode is vastly
more complicated than uh the user level
and so one of the things that could
happen is that things that are actually
racy um in the kernel space uh are
things that are actually raised in the c
space will appear as being safe to use a
level detector and one example is this
notion of interre currency this is when
a tread actually erases with itself
right so uh when I was defining data
races the common definition would imply
that there has to be two Treads involved
in creating a data race in the colel
this is not true at all what does that
mean I will get into that in a minutes
so I go to start minut um um and then
the other problem is that safe accesses
the well serialized accesses in the
kernel uh will actually appear racy and
this is because uh the kernel in the
kernel uh synchronization is done doing
other using other things besides primi
uh Mutual exclusion Primitives in
particular there's a form of
synchronization called State based
synchronization where drivers uh syn
serialize their operations based on the
state of the device and I'll talk about
that
too so so um there's only one work that
I'm aware of uh that founds data races
in the kernel mode Dynamic approach and
this is called Data collider um and the
way it works is basically so say here we
have uh this access uh we have uh the
shared variable and two Treads um data
collider will stall a tread at um um at
a shared memory access uh and then uh
and set a breckpoint on that data and
the idea is that if some other tread
comes along and tries to access it then
there'll be a collision because you know
it it obviously means that tread was not
serialized
relative to this uh to the to the to
this stalled tread and so the the cool
thing about data collider is that it has
no false positives simply because it
doesn't need to worry about the
synchronization Primitives or protocol
and things like that doesn't worry about
it it and it only actually reports
actual races races that are actually
occur so that's a strong but then the
the downsides are basically that um well
because it sols Treads um it cannot
stall Treads that are timing critical
like interrupt handling Treads so um if
the first access is from an interrupt
handling tread then the collider will
not stall it and will miss the race and
also he cannot stall Treads indefinitely
he has to let them go eventually now
this is less of a problem because um
typically maybe some no data corruption
happens if the two conflicting access
happen far apart in time but it's still
a near miss and be we would like to know
that you know the two conflicting access
occurred far apart in time we would like
to know
that um so let me get back to uh sort of
um the uh the things that might appear
that are racy in the colonel might
appear safe uh to user space so this is
inter track concurrency now what is this
all about well the idea is here that the
the kernel typically has to perform of
wide uh different types of tasks of
different priority levels and so a
kernel trade actually doesn't execute in
just one context in fact if we look in
the Linux uh Colonel um uh trads could
either be in a process context which is
dubiously named which it really means
that it's actually uh servicing a system
call from the user level another context
that a colel the same kernel TR could be
in is in a top half context where it's a
servicing interrupts uh that are
generated by the device and then in the
middle we have this bottom half and the
idea is that you know the top half is
the highest priority context and so if a
tread colel tread is doing system call
stuff and you know a packet arrives on a
network card you know we're going to
interrupt it and use that same tread to
go service that interrupt right and this
is and and then um and just to just show
as an example we have here a network
driver it starts out in uh time one it
starts out in the process context
sending packets you know send system
call um and packets arrive and so we
need to move it into sorry into the um
into the top half now the question is
what happens if it writes the same she
access the same data in both contexts
right this is actually a race even
though to a user level detector it's the
same tread so it's serialized but no
this is actually a race uh because
eventually when it returns to the
process context the the context is not
aware that another change has happened
right and so you can the driver can get
into an inconsistent state
now data collider can detect this kind
of uh this particular example here
because you know it can stall the Trad
while it's in process context and then
when the Trad tries to access it in the
in in uh in the top half it will
actually uh um uh detect that because it
will you know fire off the break point
and so the I mean the basic Insight from
here is essentially when we think about
concurrency uh raise detection in the in
the kernel we need to think not only
about the threads but actually the
context in which they're
executing now in terms of State based
synchronization so this is uh where uh
something is well serialized by the
driver but it might appear to be buggy
to uh uh you know use a level detector
now the basic idea here is that well the
devices are themselves like basically
finest State machines you can view them
as Finance State machines to go um and
here I have sort of a snippet of a
network a card where it starts out in an
inactive State and at some point it gets
connected to the PCI bus and you at some
point it gets initialized and it's ready
to do packet transmission so if I
consider this network driver code where
um well the same flag is being updated
by two different functions which could
be executed by different Treads um but
it don't seem to be serialized then
might ask is this a Ras well it turns
out not to be AAS simply because the
probe function here is only valid when
the device is in an inactive State it's
actually what takes the device from an
inactive State into uh connects it to
the to the PCI bus while the open
function only gets called while after
the device is already connected to the
PCI bus so in reality this two functions
are serialized in time they'll never be
uh they'll never uh execute concurrently
and so this is actually not a race but a
user level detector because it doesn't
see any explicit concurrency between
them will think that this is a race but
data collider will report this a data
collider will not yes no dat collider
has zero false positives like you know
yeah I had that on the slide it has zero
false positives so is a great thing
about it um but this is a problem
actually so this actually goes to a
fundamental problem which is that by by
being agnostic to synchronization
protocols data collider will not have
this sort of problem regardless of
whatever new fancy synchronization
protocol comes up in future right it's
that's really cool about it but mean I'm
guardrail we're doing trying to
understand synchronization protocol so
we're sort of susceptible to this and in
particular we uh because devices have
different kinds of the states in devices
can very why are you doing that why
don't you just use data colliders trick
um why don't I use the cider as this the
trick right I mean this trick of just uh
so combin light thing right actually
it's an interesting Direction so we're
balancing the strengths of data collider
uh actually in fact using it to help
eliminates the potential the dependence
that Dr Che has for synchronization
protocols is actually an interesting
direction of research right but but here
we just I wanted to just really push as
far as I can in terms of if I try to
understand understand the
synchronization protocols what would
that look like right and so the the
challenge that comes from this is that
devices are very different right and
they have different states and so how
can I en possibly encode all the
synchronize uh you know the different
states into my tool or even for a device
that hasn't been invented yet so it's
here at this point I had to make a
trade-off right I can't possibly track
all the possible states that a device
could have but fortunately um um the the
kernel itself is also aware of some of
the states because the kernel is
actually what invokes the driver code
right and so for example here's the the
networking stack code that invokes the
open function of a driver and you can
see here that it's actually checking to
see that the device is actually
connected to the PCI boss before it's
doing that and so in in Dr Che we
basically leverage this fact that some
of the states are already exposed to the
kernel in a standard way and so we
essentially just track those kind of uh
kernel visible States so whether a
driver d a device is connected to the
PCI whether it's generating interrupts
and things like that uh so this allows
us to uh um sort of handle a wide
variety of drivers but it also creates a
potential that we may miss um um
synchronization uh we may have some
false positives and I'll have those
numbers in a
second so in particular what are the
false positives that we have so um for
my comparison I started out we did a
collider which has zero false positives
um this is all well well okay let me
just rephrase this well dat collider has
zero false positives so uh this
experiment was done using Linux drivers
of course dat collider is only available
in Windows as far at least as when I was
doing this evaluation uh but it has zero
Falls positive so no big no big deal
here now kernel locket is a tool that I
wrote where I took a user level lock set
excuse me and I basically made it aware
of the Locking Primitives that exist in
the kernel and then I applied it and
then whoa I get all the false positives
simply because you know there's this
synchronization me uh protocol in the
kernel is different from that in the in
the in the user space so when I applied
my uh but Dr check um we get we do
better I mean we still have some false
positives and a lot of this comes from
the fact that that we are we only
tracking states that are visible to the
kernel so states that are that the
driver and the device are both a
whereabouts and they used to serialize
themselves we don't know and so this is
sort of the false postive that we're
getting here but we think that well at
least with this we're able to get a good
balance between techniques that are like
completely agnostic of synchronization
protocol and those that try to
understand synchronization
protocols but so when you say false
positive here you mean things that are
not in fact data races yes but but it's
not necessarily true that all of the
data races are are bugs right okay so
yeah so the the concept of benign races
is what you're talking about yeah so
I'll come to that in the in the uh so
I'm not reporting the number of benign
races that I have here um and I think
that's a general problem uh for Isis
detection in general right because do
you have a sense that how many of these
are actually bugs that we care about oh
these are all false positive I haven't G
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry that's posi
are all false follow question yes how
many so these are all false positives
but you can you have this other problem
that if you try to be too precise you're
so precise that you don't report any
real datab either right yes so in the
when you when you're pursuing low false
positives you have to simultaneously
make sure that you're doing something
useful also right absolutely did you
find any real races yes that's the next
slide so we found sh races in Linux
drivers and this were actual this is
after pruning away um all of the benign
races this were uh we actually found
this were real races um so some of them
were kind of interesting so one of those
races here um actually never got to
Linburg report so I mean the way I
verified this was basically you know I
have my driver uh my driver version and
then I keep looking through the commits
and and Linux um and I saw one that was
fixed but there was no comments in there
and I asked like hey guys I thought
there was a race here and yeah it was a
race but the problem there was that um
uh the race causes failur in strange
ways that are just hard to reproduce
right and so unless you're like truly
analyzing on instruction level what the
driver is doing you would actually not
find this conflict in Access um and so
um so yeah for for check we found a
total of nine races um so we decided to
like well I mean like I said uh the
collider um is on on on windows so we
try to like we looked at each race and
try to see will data collider catch this
now uh so we then model like two two
forms of dat collider one is
deterministic so one thing I mentioned
before was that dat collider is
probabilistically stalls Treads so here
we're assuming that for every uh race
here dat cider actually will you know
stall the first access right like
deterministically and there we saw that
it only uh detects just two of the nine
races and the reason was because um some
of the in this cases some the first axis
was in an interrupt Handler like for the
example I was was talking about the
first access was in an interrupt Handler
and so because dat Collide does install
it it would actually missed that race
and the other two were then the other
reason was because some of this races
actually occurred far apart in time and
so while they're not you know might not
lead to dat corruption but there are
near misses that we would like to know
about so um to sort of then you know um
sort of so for the interrupt handling we
decid decided okay let's invert it right
like so for a scenario where you know
the first axis in an interrupt Handler
why why don't we reverse it such that
the first axis is no longer an interrupt
Handler so that the collider could
actually stall that and we see that if
we did that and this is what I call
Ideal uh we then little collider catches
six out of the nine right and so the
remaining three are basically the ones
where either the two axises are B in
interrupt handlers or they are far apart
in time and so by checking more of the
of the driver execution in particular
the interrupt context we actually able
to find uh more uh uh more more races if
you have a race between two interrupt
handlers aren't they serialized Anyway
by by the the interrupt delivery
mechanism from the
device right um so let's how that arise
right actually you're right so yeah
you're right so the um actually no
that's not necessarily true so um it it
depends like so uh on a particular core
oh okay uh the in two inters in the same
driver on different cores on different
cores right so yeah two types of yeah
right but even on the same Corde the two
interrupts have different priorities or
in Linux it's
not yeah it's not in Linux yeah yeah not
in Linux yeah so it's really the the
separate
cores okay so yeah so and so this is the
sort of the balance you getting to right
which is you know you could either try
to be more more precise and detect
nothing or try to be too precise and get
too uh get too many false positives and
so we sort of think that of think that
you know we're sort of somewhere in the
middle but there are definitely room for
improvements um in at least in terms of
the false
positives all right uh so uh let's see
not to long time um dma uh so dma check
actually detects dma buffers uh bugs in
dma and how drivers use dma buffers so a
dma buffer is basically some part of a
system memory that's shared by the
driver and the device such that the
device can uh directly uh copy data off
it uh which is good for iio performance
uh so number of issues come up with how
data uh Dem buffers are used one is the
fact that they're shared so we have to
avoid the driver and the device are
racing on um on it and which I don't
know if that gets your question uh so
the the the driver should avoid racing
on the buffer while the device is using
it now the other issue that comes up is
the fact that the driver and the device
actually access the dma buffer through
different paths right right so the
driver goes through a cachee uh the dma
buffer use fiscal addresses directly and
so this leads to all sorts of coherence
issues and so you have to sort of you
know be careful in terms of how you uh
create your dma buffers in particular
you should ensure that your dma buffers
are cash
aligned um finally dma buffers a system
resources um you should the driver
should avoid leaking them or mapping
them in inconsistent ways and so all of
this rules uh can uh because uh godil
gives us an instruction trace of what
the driver is doing we can actually
write checkin tools to check for to
check for violations of this rules and
in fact I did that uh for Linux drivers
and I found about 25 violations of this
nature seven of which were races um uh
between the driver and and the device um
and uh and there were about four cases
where the D buffer was misaligned um now
what's interesting is that previously no
one's really studied this kind of
violations before um but the fact that
we have an instruction Trace allows us
to check for arbiterly check for
different rules um and in fact the way I
went back about this was I I picked up
the Linux documentation about how to
write dma and I'm like okay these are
the rules I can write this up as a check
and Rule I have an instruction trace of
the driver I am going to you know I can
find as
violations you know how long have been
in the
B well
uh um so okay um I don't know exactly
how long it's been in the bay um so my
uh Linux uh evalu kernel that I use for
my evaluations quite old actually um and
so some of the devices might look really
old but um the other thing that I found
out when CU I contacted the dma uh
expert on on on Linux is that um not all
of the bugs actually will CA uh like an
actual crash or corruption and so people
have been reluctant in actually fixing
them but it it's it it just I mean this
tool just actually shows like a new
bread of correctness checking that we
can apply on drivers which is one of
reasons why I went down this
direction how can you know if it's a
race without knowing the details of the
the hardware specification because the
way the jewel driver works is you write
some stuff and then you said a bit and
that bit says I'm done with this it
belongs to the device now so it's
perfectly safe to modify this until that
bit is so when you're when you're saying
raise here this is a raise between the
hardware and the software yes yeah so so
the the answer to that I mean to be
precise you're you're right so like but
what I've taken here is really what the
Linux kernel developers recommend in
terms of how you use dma so there's an
API for mapping a dma buffer to a device
and the idea is while that is done then
you should not touch the driver should
not touch that piece of memory and so
what I am doing is basically I'm looking
for those Maps when they happen and at
that point in time you're right you know
maybe the device hasn't started using it
so it's somewhat uh more conservative
than the than reality but it's just like
this is the encoding that I mean this is
the at least what the Linux
documentation requires now if I had the
device logic I could also encode that
and say well until the driver writes to
this particular uh you know control
register you know the device hasn't
started doing dma right um but you
actually get to a point of one of the
limitations of this work which is that
we can't directly uh the analysis cannot
directly examine the device States we're
sort of relying on the driver to do this
like to to poke the device register to
read so that's sort of get into that but
um but this was just an interesting
direction to go in especially since
issues like this don't exist in the user
level un like the DAT race exist in user
level memory check uh memory false exist
in user level so when you reported these
bugs what was the uptake in the
developer Community they were like it's
not they don't cause any crashes and
like I said this is very old
konel so so they're not particularly
interested um
so um so um so so that's basically the
bug detection Effectiveness we get by
doing LIF good style instruction grain
checking on drivers um so I built this
uh so this is my design so now I'll talk
about the end to end performance but
first let me just show how I built this
so um for my design I basically uh Built
My prototype where the analysis runs in
a separate virtual machine from the
driver and so it's isolated in that
sense um this is done in Linux as I said
I used uh Zen uh to build my
interposition
layer and um and and in particular and
also so that's sort of how this uh this
picture looks and then for my
instruction tracing I sort of rely on
the LBA Hardware assisted instruction
tracing um and so this essentially is
what uh the current prototype looks
like all right um and this is all in
simulation because Hardware tracing
doesn't exist today um and in particular
I just sort of want to point out like I
me this is sort of like a your
conventional uh system setup but uh the
we I reserve about uh half a megabytes
of memory for for holding the
instruction Trace um and in my
simulation which is this is actually in
simix I uh model I I use the uh I I
evaluat like protecting the network card
and a hard drive and the driver VM has
uh two virtual CPUs the analysis VM has
one this is a dual core system that I'm
um I'm
simulating and so what uh and in
particular I me I'm measuring end to end
performance and in particular I'm
looking at what will it cost to protect
my uh device from any of this kind of
errors in an online fashion and those
are the two drivers that I use this are
Linux these are stock Linux drivers
right so real Linux
drivers um so this is what the endend
performance looks like so here I'm
reporting the performance normalized to
Linux right and this is for the dis
workload using the postmark Benchmark uh
which test different kind of files file
operations and here I'm reporting the
transaction rate the read rates and the
write rates um and here you know we see
you know the performance is not so bad
in in some cases I mean in a lot of
cases we have less than 10% impact um
although there is like one or two where
we have like 12 to
133% um fortunately this is not uh
Quantified here um I have some backup
slides that I can get into that
yeah um what about perform what about
Network so here for Network server I'm
normalizing to uh to uh true puts that a
server will deliver normalized to Linux
same uh you know Linux as one and um I
use a range of network applications and
in general the performance seems good
reasonable for most of these benchmarks
until we get to network streaming where
um I'm losing close to 60% performance
in the case and then question is why is
network streaming so bad um well it's
because uh this just reflects the
frequency in which uh the driver
performs IO operations so the frequency
of and this are in particular I'm
reporting here the device register
accesses which is how our operations are
performed and I'm reporting in
particular the reads and the wres and so
one interesting observation is that um
um well there usually more writes than
reads espe in the network space I don't
I mean this is kind of interesting and
uh this scale is on the log scale so um
uh it is a order of magnitude difference
and we can see here that the stream
benchmarks actually performing an order
of magnitude uh more device rights than
other benchmarks or at least um so while
this shows like the worst case because
what happens there is this is the point
where the driver the liveu has to catch
up we have to stall the live G has to
catch up and so even though this shows
like the worst case here but the the the
good thing is that this doesn't seem to
be prevalent for a lot of
workloads
so and um okay all right so uh so sort
of that's the end
of guard rail and so just just to
quickly go through some of the future
work that tend to do I intend to
continue in this direction of uh looking
at device driver reliability um and in
particular the first thing I would like
to do is see if I can actually protect
the operating system kernel as well uh
but this is going to be quite
challenging relative to the
interposition layer that I had here
because uh the inter the the kernel
driver Crossing happens much more
frequently than uh the io driver
Crossing so this is going to be really
tricky and so maybe speculation might be
a good way to go rather than stalling
the operations so assume that the
operation is successful and sort of you
know unwind it if it turns out uh to to
be on uh to be on safe and then the
other challenge here is that um the
granularity with which konel and Driver
share memory is can be at a soft page
level right because in the same address
space whereas the for the device
everything's on a nice page granularity
right and so this makes it a which makes
it easier to like you know restrict
access but now when you want to restrict
access to sub parts of a page it's going
to be really hard um and so I might be
looking into things like maybe adapting
the memory allocation policies in the
kernel so that um driver data goes into
separate pages from uh from the
kernel um and of course I also want to
tackle the uh sort of the uh uh
virtualization overheads that I'm seeing
here with interposition layer where I
would like to have something like a
lightweight virtualization now um and
then asynchronous iio rights now um this
one's kind of interesting so I showed
that the device register rights were
like really the big um you know the big
uh uh killer performance killer and this
is because in the virtualized space the
iio rights become um synchronized become
synchronized um which is bad especially
if you're uh um if if if you know your
driver does a lot of do um in fact um um
while the io reads are like get worse
like maybe 5x slow down the io rights
are actually like 30 to 40x slow down
and simply because in the non-
virtualized space IO rights have be made
a synchronous anyway right so uh the
fact that you know you issue a right to
a device doesn't mean you get a response
back back but your trade can continue
executing but with virtualization
everything just sort of become
synchronous so I would love to explore
the ability to do a synchronous right
where you know the use uh the guest
continues executing while the
virtualization layer takes on the
responsibility of actually completing
the um the iio rights for
it um and so with that uh my
contributions basically have looked into
decoupling as an idea for improving the
performance of lifeguards um and I I've
shown that we can actually contain bugs
even though we're uh delaying the
detection of uh bugs and um and this is
great because then we can use uh
increasing me uh multi increasing
processor counts to actually improve uh
runtime monitoring in general I've
proposed like novel software
optimization for existing lifeguards so
these are existing lifeguards that I did
not write myself and I was able to get
good speed ups for them by basically
parallelizing them or applying compiler
optimizations and then I sort of gone
into the kernel space and say okay you
know what if we could do this sort of
detail correctness check in the colel
space and I've shown this is practical
using um uh by dein here I've shown a
framework called godil which actually
safeguards iate from device bugs and and
it does contain in using commodity
virtualization I have um created three
novel lifeguards uh for finding uh dit
races uh memory foils and dma bugs in
drivers and with that I'll conclude in
questions I think rather than questions
we should thank the speaker cuz he's had
plenty of questions
than